well I'm not sure there is life left in
checkers and I think for whatever reason
Saltzburg
did not go as planned I think on on
either side and we ended up obviously
with a bit of a standoff and unfortunate
position the Prime Minister made her
statement on Friday we saw Donald Tusk
obviously respond on Friday evening I
think the big question for those of us
in Rhapsody right who want to see a deal
I I think her no deal scenario would be
incredibly bad for our economy for our
businesses with job security for our
constituents so we want to see a deal
the question I think there has to be
answered now by by the government by the
EU leaders is what room for movement is
there how do we move on and where we
ended up last week towards talking about
continued negotiations talking about
where we are going to get to and the
issue is of course what is going to be
approved by the UK Parliament when the
negotiations are are finished and that's
a critical importance and I know that my
colleagues are going to launch this call
for a Canada style free trade agreement
tomorrow that's not going to get
approved by Parliament and has many
rules including not dealing with
Northern Ireland so it's really a
non-starter the Prime Minister's now got
to think okay what am I going to get
through Parliament so what do you think
Parliament and the Prime Minister should
be looking out because she basically
said and she did the --use put two
things on the table a free trade deal
which you just rejected in that answer
and the other one was effectively
staying in the European Economic Area in
customs union which would be accepting
uncontrolled immigration so is that the
option that you want to see well I don't
accept the premise and that would mean
uncontrolled immigration
so let's always take a step back and
well that's what a single market well
that made the whole point this is a
negotiation this is that this is the
issue and I think both sides are way of
been talking at cross-purposes for the
best part of 18 months
now and time is ticking away and so
actually getting down to brass tacks and
that's the trouble with putting binary
options on the table no checkers or No
Deal or this isn't going to work well
that's not going to work actually the
point is there isn't a sweet spot I'm
unfurling the opinion that can be found
both with the EU and then with
Parliament it's a question of unlocking
it that's why carrying on with the
negotiations I think Dominic robbed the
brexit Secretary's right it's a time for
cool heads and getting on with the
negotiations but having accessed the
single market by the European free trade
area membership where we were a founding
member the UK of that and their
definition of free movement is different
it's free movement of workers and I
think that's important because the
British public have a much more nuanced
understanding of immigration but I think
that their debate reflects people can
come here to work to pay their taxes to
contribute and I think people understand
that look I'm sitting in Loughborough
you know big University just been named
congratulations Sunday Times university
of the year now we have EU students EU
academics coming here all the time it
brings diversity to our town and I think
people openly understand that I want
that that flexibility to continue but if
that immigration quality is going to
have to have to change and the other
issues about having a custody the Prime
Minister's right to saying that okay we
can't have the breakup of the Union and
so that's again the Canada option
doesn't deal with that nice that nice
name drop there for the University well
done for getting that money now hear it
here at labor conference
lots of people talk about the idea of a
second referendum with both Jeremy
Corbyn and Tom Watson opening the door
for that is that something that you
would support
I personally don't support it and I
actually think that this is something
now which MPs who are elected in 2017
have got to step up to the plate and
sort out if the reasons I've just set
out I think there is a position that can
be supportive 5 parliamentarians across
the house and I think that that's what
the government also needs to be doing is
working to build a coalition if you like
of support for a position we're leaving
the EU that gets parliamentary support
I think it's wholly wrong for the Labour
Party to say categorically the flavours
frontbench and saying that they won't
vote for anything that's not in the
national interest but I think a second
vote as I say I think it's a distraction
I think it would rerun 2016 I also think
this sabre-rattling about a general
election in order to potentially get a
majority to get from 3 look we've been
there we did that in 2017 it didn't go
so well we didn't get majority we lost
33 really good colleagues from our
benches we do not need to go through
that again
it's that any piece of step up the plate
and sort this out now as elected
representatives otherwise I think our
democracy will be in big trouble you're
someone who's supposed to remain you've
got very good relationships of course
with other of your colleagues who fact
remain how many Conservative MPs do you
think would support the idea of a second
referendum well I think there's probably
a handful I'm probably saw talking about
those who have come out I think so far
it's about half a dozen or so I think
there's there's this growing interest
you know I've had since last week a
number of people say to me that although
they are not keen on the idea of
recommended they're not keen on the idea
of a second vote actually given the
Prime Minister's own discovery knows
description of this being at an impasse
maybe a second vote is the only way to
resolve this and that's not my position
but I understand why people are thinking
there's got to be something to break the
deadlock my preferred option as I say is
to find a deal that that Parliament will
support rather than have the distraction
of a passing legislation to have a
second vote and as I say the idea of
having a general election saw all this
out and I think you know is bad news all
around all that that does is potentially
you know delay things that a party say
that's what they want that is not
responsible and actually you're sitting
there in Liverpool what we should be
talking about this week is you know the
support there appears to be for for
militant from the 1980s the fact that
our labor that venture has got to have
armed bodyguards now because she's a
critic of Jeremy Corbyn you know this is
the sort of thing that we should be
talking about that the label on to
really nationalize the railways
seriously that their priority when they
get into into government so look there
is a there's a deal that can be done put
to Parliament and approved and then we
can obviously get beyond to you know to
look at the other issues that are facing
us as a country well let's look shall we
at the state of the Conservative Party
have been very critical there about the
situation of the Labour Party but on
your own side it does appear that you're
fighting like cats and dogs over Bret's
there's lots of people who were very
aggressively if you like criticizing the
Prime Minister have future being openly
discussed even let's suppose at loyalist
so or people on the modernizing wing of
the party saying that actually after
she's sealed the deal on brexit she
should stand aside for a new generation
is that your view do you think Theresa
Mays the woman to lead the Conservatives
into the next election no I've been
quite open about that I think that term
that she's she's not and I think if
anyone in in Downing Street thinks that
that she is and then you know that that
would be a concern and my worry is that
a lot of time there's a focus I
understand it for our party conference
on on know shoring up but know her
position we've got to do what's right in
in the country's interest having a
leadership election now would not be in
the country's interest I think a prime
minister has got a very difficult task
that she
as no absolute leaders just kept going
and resilient ly kept going and that is
to be hugely admired there the
difficulty is that actually as ever
there are a number of you know key
voices on on both sides of the argument
particularly a lot of hard brexit heirs
who absolutely want to bring the prime
minister down I mean there's talk today
of you know she's got another 10 days
and then no we're going to start talking
to Graham Brady who heads up our 1922
committee that would run any leadership
contest no this is not a move that would
help the country in order to get to the
best position after brexit which does
least damage to our economy and that's
what we have conservatives should be
should be focused on Europe's always
been a big fault line in our party of
course it has but actually in the
majority of the parliamentary party and
I think their membership want us to
focus on the faults of the Labour Party
want us to focus on getting a good deal
it supports the economy and then moving
on and then just finally while we have
you going to use is running a campaign
to try and set up an independent
commission to secure new debates at
every general election is that something
that you'd welcome well I think the
leaders debates are are here to stay and
I think that it's someone those things
that I think it'll be a bit of a fool's
errand really for parties now to to not
take part it was something that was
noticed at the last general election and
of course I think that the leaders
debates know things like the numbers and
how they're constituted everything else
is perhaps a matter for discussion I
certainly found as a campaigner that the
difficulty was in 2010 particularly it
all focused on the Leeds debates it was
hard to engage locally when those were
going on the run-up and all that that
they're talking about them afterwards
and but I do think that actually leaders
debates are are here to stay and and I
think that that's the that's that's the
right position that's going to be a part
of our election campaigns going forward